Donald Trump looking as dark orange as
he has ever looked has put out a series
of new statements that are absolutely
chilling in terms of what they mean
regarding freedom of the press freedom
freedom of the justice system the
ability of elected officials to be
able to influence prosecution which is
something Trump really wants to do Trump
put out a statement in which he says he
wants the psycho special counsel
investigating him to go after Barack
Obama and Joe Biden Obama why he wants
them to do that isn't completely clear
take a look at this dangerous claim uh
that dangerous statement that Trump is
making Mad Dog psycho prosecutor Jack
Smith
sounds like a very innocent name doesn't
it yeah Jack Smith just so common so so
pedestrian put there for only one reason
by Biden and the weaponized justice
department
should stop this Witch Hunt altogether
or at a minimum should give Biden Obama
and everybody else he almost said Obama
did you see that he struggled with it
and almost said Obama hunt all
together or at a minimum should give
Biden Obama and everybody else the same
treatment as they give me right now of
course that's really weird that's like
if you're accused of murder and you go
Hey listen you should give my high
school bully the same treatment well but
that is is there reason to think that
the high school bully committed murder
because otherwise why would we do that
doesn't make sense because we have two
sets of Justice in our country that's
true but it's not Democrats and
Republicans it's wealthy Elites versus
everybody else and the people won't
stand for it oh
there you go so a very powerful
declaration from a confused looking
Donald Trump trump also during this
statement and I've not seen him do this
before he positions himself almost like
he's running against both the Democratic
and Republican parties which is very
very interesting and he claims to be
leading both parties it's it's a
confused statement see if you can
understand it
massive and unprecedented
prosecutorial misconduct due to Trump
derangement syndrome and very very big
leads against both parties in the polls
he's leading both parties what what's
causing it we can't let it happen it's
illegal as can be we're going to stop it
we're not going to let them win
elections by using the law illegally
thank you right you can't use the law
illegally and for people wondering this
does seem to be primarily a lighting
issue that is afflicting Trump here I
don't know if antifa is in charge of the
lighting for these videos but Trump says
he's he's leading both parties what does
that even mean this this I I struggled
to get through this video without
breaking out an uncontrollable laughter
because it's so so so bizarre Trump also
calling out Reverse Racism in this very
same video which you know again it's
it's either racist or it's not and they
continue to be confused
crooked Democrat prosecutors many of
them racists in Reverse they are
absolute racists in Reverse in Reverse
is being racist in reverse the same as
being the victim of racism maybe that's
what Trump means are trying to steal a
second presidential election are they
they did it in 2020 and we're not going
to let them do it again in 2024. Now
understand what Trump means is I tried
to steal a presidential election in 2024
in 2020 and I am going to try to steal
another one in 2024. that's really what
he means here make America great again
there you go so Donald Trump putting out
these strange there's he's almost like
vlogging they're almost like video blogs
and none of it makes any sense but this
is increasingly the way that Trump
apparently wants to be communicating
with the followers that he has and part
of the advantage I will admit is that
often these videos are done within
little pieces with tons of jump Cuts
it's we've seen behind the scenes video
of Trump trying to record a longer
narrative
and it's very glitchy and it doesn't it
doesn't like go very well for him so
this may be a way that Trump can cut
these things together to make them sound
a little bit more coherent so a really
strange statement and now I want to
focus in more specifically about a
couple other aspects of this very same
speech one of our sponsors is paired the
app for couples every day paired gives
you and your partner questions quizzes
games to have fun to stay connected to
deepen your conversations and get to
know each other better what's great
about it is you don't even have to be in
the same room especially with the baby
right now my girlfriend and I are quite
busy and paired really helped us to stay
connected you get a daily question to
answer you can't see your partner's
answer until you answer yourself and
their questions about everything
relationship life intimacy other things
and all of the exercises were developed
by academic psychologists and expert
relationship therapists as well
questions like what makes you feel lucky
in your relationship great when you want
to remember and have gratitude a really
great thing what's an activity you could
try together this month actually gets
people thinking about things to do it
can go in really funny directions as
well but it just always feels like time
well spent head over to paired.com
Pacman for a seven day free trial and 25
off a subscription the link is down
below